amazon
added the ex-nsa spy chief
who presided over the edward snowden
scandal
to its board thursday it has elected
former national security agency
chief keith alexander to its board
alexander presided over the nsa
when the edward snowden's scandal broke
snowden reacted to the news of
alexander hiring to amazon sync it turns
out hey alexa
is short for hey keith alexander which
is pretty powerful
general keith alexander presided as
director national agency from 2005 to
2014 after which he founded his own
cyber security company
iron net security is this
something deeper than what it is or is
amazon just trying to protect themselves
against a cyber attack well he was the
first
general keith alexander was the first
commander of the u.s cyber command
okay so if there's anybody that knows
anything about setting up and
establishing
it's him yeah i think this is just a
smart addition to the board
you you just recruited a guy that can
provide a lot of value relationships
and insights of people are trying to
come after your company are you reading
into this adam or no that's
no any time that the word general is in
the sentence i just throw it over to sao
paulo
you take this one matt uh general mattis
general keith alexander
you know i i the the story that i have
here is
regarding edward snowden and this is
where my problem with the media
is edward snowden a good guy is he a bad
guy
is he anti-american is he pro-american
this guy i don't know this guy's name
has been out there for so long
yeah he he just he's a guy that just
doesn't want to be infringed on he wants
his privacy
right just leave me leave it that's what
it would seem and he was the um
why can't i think of the word the uh
when you when you
whistleblower thank you kai
whistleblower for everything that was
happening
um this was in during uh
mid to mid you know 2010 i want to say
maybe before that point is this edwin
snowden guy
edward snowden guy seems like a legit
guy but the media has portrayed him to
be sort of a
bad guy i mean what's your take on
snowden i mean who did he expose
give me the name of who he exposed
expose the government okay
who who was in the government when he
exposed i want to say bush
okay who else did he expose
who else did snowden expose nsa who else
i mean obama who i don't know he was
doing
everybody hillary everybody put it out
there
yes right and it was everybody okay so
when they do that you know you're gonna
have the government that's gonna call
the media saying hey listen
you guys gotta kind of uh cut this part
out and this is a little bit too much
and uh
you know i'm not happy about this and
you know sometimes like what he's saying
hiring somebody like that
you know you're really hiring his
rolodex
amazon is hiring keith alexander's
rolodex it's it's the contact
you talk about from 2005 to 2014 that's
nearly 10 years
okay what's his rolodex look like in the
space of cyber security and is that the
rolodex that
jeff bezos wants of course of course he
wants that he wants that roller deck so
he wants to call those contacts that he
has
with amazon i think you know on basil's
move good for him for getting it
i also understand why the media would
turn this into a story it's probably
something you got to write about
because it's always interesting when
things like this takes place like when
huawei when when a uk in one of the
scenarios hired somebody a former
executive from huawei
a little bit strange when you get some
of these companies that are hiring
former cyber security from china
i mean this happened just last year you
got to pay attention to it but i don't
think it goes
much more than that with basically are
you a snowden
fan anti-snowden i am neutral i i am
taking on i am
all for anybody that whistle blows on
the government who's trying to
manipulate against the people what i'm
not against
is when whistleblowers uh whistleblow
against a country's
plan of attack or strategy i don't think
that's healthy for the people because
the enemy knows what they're going to do
next
but if you're going to whistleblow
somebody on what they did 10 20 30
years ago or even in emails when you
know clinton or some of that stuff i'm
with that we need to know what's going
on there and the manipulation part of it
so
yes i'm with that part you